jackie what's up dr g how are you today
i'm so good how are you good thank you
thanks so much for taking my call
you betcha what can i do to help um yeah
so today i'm having
troubles connecting with my
sister-in-law and i was hoping maybe you
can help me
try to understand why this is and maybe
ways to fix it
okay tell me how you're having trouble
just uh having trouble connecting
yeah so you know a little back story um
she met my brother-in-law and
i think their relationship moved very
quickly um you know
they met they got um married they're
expecting a baby all
like within a year or less okay and so i
feel like i didn't get a chance to
really
get to know her i only met her a couple
times and then all the serious stuff
happened so i feel like you know we're
cordial enough
but a lot of times i feel like um i'm
kind of carrying like the conversations
on my back like
i'll ask her a question you know like
what's your favorite food and it'll just
be like oh italian and then the
conversation kind of ends
and so i just feel like i would love a
better relationship where
i mean in an ideal world maybe more of
like a friendship you know what i mean
just because
you know we see each other somewhat
often so um
and also just to get you know um again
just
to have a better relationship i think
that we just it's kind of awkward and
sure and again i don't know i'm just
trying to figure out like if it's coming
from me like am i
like deep down for some reason like i
don't know jealous or like you know it's
a sister-in-law thing where it's like
you know we're both you know i don't
know
not competition necessarily but just
trying to figure out how i can maybe
connect with her better
do you miss your brother
yeah you know i do but also another
thing is that i
i see them and again i know it's none of
my business it's not my relationship but
she's
she's snapped on him a few times in
front of me and i just feel like
again i i don't intervene i'm kind of
just like she's not my business
but i don't appreciate that sure you
know what i mean yeah totally
but i think that's probably good for you
yeah so you're defensive of your brother
you love him
you miss him you are right to not get in
the middle that's his wife
and that's their relationship dynamic
however weird it is for you
right until she becomes abusive which of
course then you're going to get involved
um
but yeah you're gonna have you're gonna
have your snap judgments here's what you
need to do and it's simple jackie
and it's directed to the point i want
you to reach out to her do you all live
in the same community the same area can
you all get together in person
yeah okay i want you to invite her to
coffee
are you even allowed to do that in los
angeles i don't know how that works um
you know we can have out we can order it
and then take it out to a park
okay so i want you to i want you to take
her out
i want you to pay and i want you to tell
her
you are a part of my family i'm i
consider you a sister now
and i want to develop a great
relationship with you
this is super weird because we're both
grown-ups and so i'm being vulnerable
here
i want to have a great relationship with
you and i want to grow
and develop a friendship with you how do
we start
and i want you to be that vulnerable
with her because here's the deal
you're gonna peter along for the next
decade
dropping a little hint here what do you
think about this here
and then on the other side of that scale
you're gonna see her nitpick your
brother you're gonna see her make fun of
him when he puts on some weight you're
gonna
see her treat your nieces and nephews
differently than you would treat them
and that scale is going to get out of
whack and what you are going to avoid
this whole time is being vulnerable with
her
and it's going to end in an explosion
and then your poor brother is going to
have to choose between his sister and
his wife
you can cut all that crap out by just
taking her out on the front end of this
deal
and saying you're in my family now
you are my sister i want to grow to get
to know you and i'm being super
vulnerable and this is weird for both
of us i'm making it awkward and i'm
sorry but i want to grow to love you
i want to grow to be connected with you
i want you to start coming over and
hanging out at the house
i want to know what you love what you
don't love and
let's just get weird right nick miller
style let's just get weird
and let's develop a grown-up
relationship
we don't know how to do this we don't
have any skills for how to make
grown-up adult friendships that's why
we're all lonely as
old people after we get out of college
we just have like one or two
people at work and then we just get
lonely right so you are going out on a
limb
and you got to be ready for this her
looking at you saying
oh sure that'd be great and then never
calling you again
you've got to be ready for your brother
to be like what is the matter with you
did you seriously take my wife to a park
and ask your quote to be your friend
that's what serial killers do you weirdo
right you have to be ready
because relationship is about risk but
what you're doing is you're
short-circuiting a decade of uncertainty
a decade of
judgment and back and forth and poking
and prodding all that
you're just going to go for it you're
going to risk you're going to be
vulnerable
you're going to say i want to be your
friend you're my sister i love you let's
do this
and then you're gonna let her respond my
gut is my hope is that she's gonna go oh
thank god i didn't know how to do this i
know he talks so highly about you his
sister he loves
i feel like i'm always competing with
you and that sounds weird like flowers
in the attic because i know you and your
brother
aren't like like that but you all have a
great relationship and i feel all weird
in the middle of it
and she's gonna be relieved ah thank god
so good for you for wanting to connect
your family deeper
go for it jackie go for it and then i
want you to call me back and let me know
how that conversation went
and you may call back and be like
deloney you suck you idiot i was
vulnerable and i ruined everything
good for you now you know you get you
get a decade of your life back right and
i didn't even charge you for it
that was free advice right jackie so
thank you so much for the call